All right,
let's talk about college and education
this week.
Perhaps the best way to dive into this
discussion is to first tell you guys a
bit about my own personal experience.
I went to public school in Long Island
from kindergarten through high school
and then onto binghamton university.
New York actually has a pretty great
college system for decades and since I
was a resident,
tuition was discounted to just a
fraction of what most colleges costs.
Now I got a solid education at an
affordable public school and have used
my degree in political science to do
exactly what you all tuned in to see me
do now.
It was my education that led me to
guiding conversations about important
topics with interesting people.
I will spend a lot of time in college
smoking pot and listening to fish.
Uh,
but that's another story for another
time.
This show has been devoted to discussing
ideas.
That very concept is rooted in a good
education in which you can question what
you believe.
This is the number one reason to go to
college,
to learn how to think critically.
When we talk about a battle of ideas,
you can only have that battle when
people know what their ideas are
actually based on when we talk about
free speech,
you can only really talk about knowing
why free speech is important and what
happens to societies that don't have it.
When we talk about the dysfunction of
our political process,
you can really only understand it if you
know the basic tenants of how it was
designed to work in the first place and
when we talk about the complex issues
facing the Middle East,
you can really only understand them if
you know the history of the countries
and the people living there.
I didn't learn all of these things in
college,
but the foundation of having my ideas
challenged and learning new things
absolutely was built.
Their learning is something I try to do
on this show each week and it's why I
have no problem telling you guys.
I don't know everything and I don't have
all the answers.
At this very moment.
The American education system and our
colleges in particular are under total
assault from the backwards forces on the
left who don't want open discussion and
would rather stifle ideas they don't
like such as critiquing a certain
religion or questioning the motives of
the social justice movement because of
the authoritarian crusade to shelter
young people from ideas that might
challenge them.
We've created safe spaces where we once
had rigorous debate.
We now issue trigger warnings where we
once were brave enough to hear ideas
that would make us uncomfortable.
The attack on the honest debate has
gotten so bad.
It is now hard to tell if this
intellectual affliction is coming from
the students or from the faculty between
the professor calling for muscle to
remove press from a demonstration at the
University of Missouri to students
demanding the dean be fired at Yale for
defending the freedom of expression to
my former guests,
Milo yiannopoulos being shouted down
while talking about free speech at
rutgers just two weeks ago.
The tentacles of intolerance are taking
root at colleges all across America,
and it's the ideas which take root
today.
That will be the ideas that lead us into
the future.
That's the real risk here.
We must be willing to exercise our free
speech more thoughtfully than to only
use it to prevent other people from
exercising.
There's we have a right to free speech
in this country.
Not a right to not be offended.
My guests,
just last week,
Ben Shapiro just had a speech about
conservatism at cal State University,
canceled after leftist activist
protested his presence on campus.
The school president said that Ben would
be invited back,
but as part of a panel,
when more diverse views can be heard,
well that concept doesn't sound terrible
in and of itself.
Let's really understand what happened
here.
When the authoritarians be they on the
left or on the right,
when they like your views,
you can speak freely and there's no need
for counter voices.
When they don't like your views,
well you will be screamed at or outright
canceled.
This is dangerous and it's happening
more and more every day.
I sat here for over an hour with Ben and
although I didn't agree with him on an
array of topics,
I listened and I learned from the
response we got on the episode,
so did many of you,
even if all you learned was that you
completely disagree with him.
That's what conversation is all about
and it's that precious space where you
learn to think on your own,
which is exactly what the point of
higher education is supposed to be.
College is the single most important
place where ideas must be challenged.
As I say all the time,
let the battle of ideas happen and the
good ones will eventually win by
slandering opponents,
demanding professors be fired and
canceling speaking events.
These college kids are unwittingly
strengthening ideas that will one day
silence of them.
Eventually the day will come when they
want to say something that's considered
unpopular and they will then be
subjected to the same practices that
they themselves are propagating right
now.
The second they leave the safety of
their college quad and are hit with the
harsh reality of the real world.
They'll be ill prepared to deal with
anyone who doesn't share their myopic
view of how things should be to help me
dissect this crisis and that's exactly
what it is,
is Professor Gad said,
God is an author,
professor and evolutionary behavioral
scientists at the John Molson School of
business at Concordia University in
Montreal,
Canada.
God is also a fearless defender of free
speech and an outspoken advocate of free
expression in an academic climate that
doesn't look too kindly on these things.
These days.
We're going to dive deep into what has
happened at college campuses all over
the world and why free speech must be
defended at all costs.
Once again,
get in your safe space.
You've been triggered war,
and let's exercise some of that free
speech while we still have it set as a
professor,
author,
Youtube Creator,
defender of free speech and secular
ideas known as the godfather and he's
spreading the sad truth.
I think you're going to spread a little
of it right here.
Thank you so much for having me again.
So I'm very excited to talk to you.
I say that to all my guests because I'm
always excited to talk to people,
but I particularly mean it today because
you joined me for the first test show a
all the way back in August.
Uh,
people think that
Sam Harris was the first guest,
but technically Gad sad was the first
repeat guest.
So you now are the first.
You were the first guest,
you were the first repeat guest and,
and you're doing so much cool stuff in
this space.
This,
this sort of,
uh,
what,
what do we want to call ourselves now?
What space are we in?
Fighters have good ideas.
I like that.
All right,
so I want to get into,
uh,
the work that you do.
I want to talk about your books.
I want to talk about your tweets and I
want to talk about your youtube channel,
but I saw you do an interview with
astronaut Omani.
Uh,
which was really,
really fascinating.
Talk about your history.
So you were born in Lebanon and I'm
going to let you take it away.
Sam was born in Lebanon,
a 19,
late 1964.
So now everybody knows my age.
There you go.
Um,
lived there for 11 years and then the
civil war broke out in the mid
seventies.
It became very,
very difficult to be Jewish in Lebanon.
Uh,
and so we really had to leave under
imminent threat of execution in Lebanon.
Everybody carries an internal ID card,
very much like a passport,
but for,
for the country itself.
And on that ID card is stated very
clearly what your religion is.
And so if you are stopped at particular
roadblocks by militia who were not
sympathetic to you being Jewish,
it wasn't going to turn out well.
And as you might imagine,
most of the militia at that point,
you know,
you wouldn't have cleared those
roadblocks.
And so we really needed to leave.
And so we left Lebanon,
um,
the day that we left Lebanon and we
cleared the airspace of A.
Well,
Lebanon,
the,
as the captain had mentioned that,
uh,
my wife and my wife,
my mother takes out a star of David,
puts it around my neck and says,
now you don't have to hide who you are.
Okay,
so let's,
let's back up before we get to your
escape because of,
for your escape.
There was some pretty amazing stuff that
happens.
So your parents were kidnapped by PLO.
Terrorists later.
Okay.
So we,
we emigrated to Canada and late 75 then
for the next four years,
my parents kept going back and forth
from Montreal to Lebanon.
They really couldn't extricate
themselves fully from their previous
life in Lebanon and on one of those
trips in 1980,
there were kidnapped by a photo.
Yeah.
You had a guest,
but no relation,
no relation,
but Fatah is sort of now it's considered
the moderate version.
The moderate to Hamas.
Moderate in the Middle East is a very
attentive term.
Sure.
And so they were kidnapped.
They disappeared for a,
I think it was eight days at the time
that it was happening when my siblings
are much older than me,
we're trying to find a way to rescue
them or even know if they're still
alive.
I had been lied to.
I was told that they had some financial
problems.
That's why there was so much upheaval in
the house.
So during those eight days or my parents
had disappeared,
I didn't know that they were potentially
dead.
What they were finally rescued.
They were rescued actually because my
mother's best friend at the time,
her name was,
uh,
was the personal dresser of half as an
asset.
And so through those connections we were
able to pinpoint which militia group had
them.
And I guess was he the president of a
president of Syria,
the president of Syria,
Syria.
And then through him I think a Yasser
Arafat got involved and finally they
found them.
They were with a group led by Don.
I'm going on my memory here from when I
was 15.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
they were rescued.
And I think one of the things that you
might remember from the story with,
uh,
my discussion with Astro,
when my parents were eventually rescued,
uh,
my father had a severe injury from
having been beaten with a coalition of
cove and he had a temporary stroke
paralysis in his face,
which eventually subsided.
And in my mother's case,
I remember that one of the things that
had really disturbed me as a 15 year old
young male was whether she had been
raped.
And I remember that shortly after they
were rescued and came back to Montreal.
I asked her,
the only time I've ever brought up the
subject and she said that while they
repeatedly threatened her
psychologically would rape,
that they hadn't raped her.
And I don't know if that's true or not,
we just sort of dropped the subject and
never raised it again.
Yeah.
So I don't know that you can know the
answer to this,
but what were,
what were they trying to get out of your
brain?
What was the advantage of,
of taking x pats that were now Canadians
and kidnapping?
Yeah.
Great.
Actually,
it's one of the seven deadly sins of
greed,
one of the,
uh,
the owner of a building where my father
had a store in the lobby was trying to
low ball my father to sell the store and
thinking that of course as Jews they
weren't a very precarious situation.
He had hired these militia to try to
extract from them a confession that they
were Israeli spies and the only thing
and then if they would then execute them
as Israeli spies somehow magically he
could get that sore.
Luckily for my parents,
of course they didn't confess to that
because they're not Israeli spies and
that's what kept them alive for those
eight days because there was an ulterior
motive to get them to sign those
confessions.
Wow,
that's really incredible.
So now I know why I jumped ahead with
the story about your parents because
what happened to you getting out of
Lebanon I thought was fascinating.
So you were talking about going through
the checkpoints and being in a car.
Yes.
And you have a very foggy memory of.
Exactly.
So I remember very,
very well actually we had hired PLO
militia.
I mean,
you think about the guys that you see
today,
the Isis guys,
how they look?
Well,
I've,
that's what I grew up with now.
Those guys were contracted to drive us
to the airport,
uh,
precisely because by close to the baby
with international airport,
there were a lot of militia checkpoints
of Palestinians and there was no way
you're going to get through that if,
if they weren't sympathetic to,
to you.
So,
but of course they could take you and
they can take it to the ditch and shoot
you so you don't really know what's
going to happen.
So I remember being picked up by these
guys.
I remember getting to the airport and
then the story would end up on the
plane,
but everything in between I have zero
recollection of that.
And I once asked my parents what
happened and she said that,
uh,
as we were going through different
neighborhoods that would have been
hostile to Palestinian militia,
for example,
Christian groups,
everybody was engaging one another very
much like a Rambo movie.
We were at the bottom of the floor of
the car,
sort of being hidden.
All of that.
I have zero recollection of that.
Yeah.
It's so fascinating because it shows you
how complex the entire situation with
Lebanon and the Palestinians and the
Israelis is because you had,
you had Palestinian militia people being
paid off to help Jews escaped Lebanon
because of their civil war.
I mean,
it really.
If you,
if you map this whole thing,
people will go,
this makes no sense.
Well,
I have,
I've actually written about this,
that,
you know,
Muslims were trying to kill us and
Muslims saved us.
Right?
So you can sort of have a blanket
statement,
you know,
all Muslims,
right?
That's an.
Oh,
so you don't believe in all Muslims are
bad.
Okay.
Go ahead.
That outright they're getting.
Because we don't want you.
He misquoted.
So you must feel a sort of very strange
when a right now,
you know,
Hezbollah is sort of taking over Lebanon
and they're fighting in Syria and that's
your home country and it's teetering on
democracy or it's democracy I should
say,
is teetering.
Uh,
how do you feel about Lebanon now?
And you might be with you.
I do so much.
I,
you know,
my,
I have two children,
uh,
so between my wife and I,
we speak five languages,
so I speak French,
English,
Arabic and Hebrew.
She speaks English,
French and Armenian,
and yet our children only speak French
and English because by virtue of living
in Montreal and I really regret the fact
that we don't have the opportunity to
take our children back to Lebanon,
for example,
one year visiting professorship at
American University of Beirut,
you know,
dumped them in that context.
They could come back fluent Arabic
speaker,
speaker.
Could you do it?
Is there because because of the
political situation or you know,
and in Beirut,
if you make a left turn here than there
is an isis recruitment center perhaps.
You mean you don't know who's the Nice
Guy,
who's the bad guy,
right?
It won't take much for people to find
out.
Number one,
that I'm Jewish,
number two,
that I've written quite forcefully about
some of these issues.
It's very easy for you to disappear in
the trunk of a car.
Right?
So I certainly wouldn't feel comfortable
given the current situation.
Cigarettes now I've been told I have a
lot of friends that have said,
look,
we can guarantee your security come back
and so on.
Can you really?
So,
so I'd rather not.
And certainly not when I have young
children.
Right.
So before the civil war,
and I know you were,
you were 12 when it happened,
so you were pretty young.
11,
11.
Do you,
what,
what was it like to be Jewish?
There was actually.
Okay.
So that's,
that's a very issue because oftentimes
people will say,
oh,
but Jews were treated very nicely.
I mean,
yes,
nicely in the sense that they aren't
daily decapitations the square and
central square,
right?
You could go about your business,
but everything is nice until the
decapitations happen,
right?
So,
uh,
you were tolerated,
right?
I mean,
people knew you were Jewish.
They didn't necessarily bother you
everyday,
but antisemitism pervades the fabric of
every possible element of society in
those regions.
Now that doesn't mean that everybody's
an antisemite,
but you know,
you just be quiet,
don't,
don't signal your belongingness to this
group.
Be understated.
Yeah.
And then once the civil war happened,
sort of the rules were just changed,
right?
Is that,
is that what it was?
Basically you guys felt that whatever
side wins this thing,
we're finished.
I mean,
there,
there were Jews that were killed and it
would have only been a matter of time
where somebody would have found us and
killed us.
So it really was under imminent threat
of execution.
I mean,
we either get out or that.
Yeah.
So I know that a certain amount of
people will be watching this and we'll
say,
well wait,
I don't understand because God is a
extremely outspoken atheist,
but he's here repeated several times
that you're Jewish.
How do you reconcile that?
Because I've met a few people on it,
had Ali Rizvi who's an atheist Muslim
and we talked about how he reconciles
it.
Uh,
and there's been a couple of other
people where we,
the way I reconcile it for myself,
how do you reconcile that?
So the way I would answer that is that
Judaism,
or to be Jewish as a multifaceted
identity,
there's a cultural element.
There is a historical element,
there is a shared context history,
there's just the shared history,
shared lineage,
uh,
one of which is adherence to a set of
religious doctrines.
And so I could choose to ignore those
doctrines and still say I do belong to a
group of people,
uh,
that can be traced back in this manner
through genealogy.
Right.
And so in that sense,
I'm very Jewish,
uh,
but in the religious element,
I'm not at all Jewish.
Yeah.
Do you think you don't get a certain
cred of being from the Middle East
because of that?
Because there is a sense and we're going
to sit down and we followed the gosh a
little bit later,
but you know,
I've known him online for over a year.
I just,
because he said that he had Palestinian
ancestry,
I just assumed he was Muslim.
I didn't know until we met two weeks ago
I had dinner that his family actually
was Christian and that was just a silly
and sloppy thinking on my part.
But do you feel that you sort of don't
get some of the credit of being a real
middle easterner?
I mean,
it depends on who you're speaking,
I guess from the people on the left that
I spend so much time,
you know,
once I break down the break,
break down with the flawless Arabic than
those kinds of concerns go away.
Right.
Because it's,
it's,
it's quite impressive for somebody to
accuse you of that.
And then when your mother.
I mean everything about us as Arabic.
I mean,
yes,
we happen to be Jewish,
but I mean,
you know,
culturally we're were Arabic,
right,
with Arab Jews.
So it's very difficult for people to
levy that charge.
Although I have interesting a personal
anecdote.
When I was a graduate student,
a doctoral student at Cornell,
uh,
I became friends with a lot of Arabic
students,
uh,
as what typically happened because I
have more in common with them than I
might have with the Jewish guy from
Poland.
Right,
right.
Sure.
Uh,
and so at one point,
one of these guys who had gone for
coffee,
he said to me,
you know,
I really,
I really liked again.
I said,
well,
why do you say that as though you're so
surprised?
It was,
well,
you know,
because,
well,
you know,
because you're Jewish,
but you know,
but you're not a Jew Jew.
Right,
right.
I said,
no,
I'm a Ju Ju Ju Ju.
He goes,
no,
come on.
You know what I mean?
You're not a Jew.
So in that case,
what he was saying is you're not really
the archetype of what I imagined a Jew
to be you really Arabic and so it's the
opposite of what you asked.
I think all of this is so fascinating.
The reason I like talking about it,
it's very similar to what I was
discussing with Tara Fatah few days ago.
That identity is so malleable actually.
It's so,
not necessarily your religion or your
history or even your ethnicity or where
you were born in nationality because
it's all of those things.
And I guess that's why I hate identity
politics so much because I realize that
most people are like,
you are like me,
that pick and choose what to believe in
and that secular values ultimately are
the things that should move us forward
as a society.
Speaking of identity politics,
uh,
and privileged scores,
I should mention that.
I know you're privileged now.
I've lost some points because my skin is
a bit lighter that summer,
but I've made sure to put on a bit of
weight so that I could gain on the
fattism score.
So it an in a homeostatic mechanism
whereby maintain my victimology score at
a certain point.
Right.
But the but the fat thing is way lower
on the list than the other thing.
I'll bring it back and then the religion
things up here,
depending on what religion is.
Such a,
people should be walking around with
cards and you just hand it to him and be
like,
well here's my shit.
And mother underprivileged.
I did a thing on buzzfeed the other day
about privilege.
Did you see this one?
But I didn't say they did it.
How privileged are you?
And I got a 42 out of hundreds that I
wasn't privileged at all.
Now it's it pretty great.
I'm not really.
I thought I'm going to,
I got to tell people about.
I'm off the charts on that one.
Yeah,
you'd be,
you'd get a negative sick.
I'm fantastic.
Yeah.
Um,
okay.
So I wanted to get some of your history
out of the way,
but let's talk about what you're doing
now.
Um,
so you are a professor and you do
research on your own and all that.
We've got your book,
the consuming instincts as signed copy
for you decided already signed that and
if I see it on Ebay as a means for you
to try to fund your Malibu House,
I'll be upset.
No,
no,
don't worry about the Malibu House.
I'm working on it in other,
other ways.
Um,
so tell me a little bit about what
brought you to the world of academic.
So I've always known,
I mean there were two things that I was
really good at and interested in soccer
and studying books.
Uh,
I was certainly going quite a,
my soccer career was going quite well,
but then I had some serious injuries and
other circumstances that don't allow me
to pursue that.
And so that accelerated my move to
academia and so I always do.
I mean,
I didn't even take any breaks between my
degrees.
I just went through,
it's through,
through my phd,
it's straight to professorship because I
never imagined doing anything else,
uh,
in terms of the work that I do,
if that's what we talk about.
Uh,
so what I,
what I do is I basically Mary
evolutionary psychology and biology to
the study of consumer behavior.
So the idea being that what makes us
consumed the way that we are is
ultimately rooted in some evolutionary
mechanisms.
Why is it that men are the ones who are
most likely to succumb to the
pornographic addiction?
Uh,
what,
uh,
how do women's hormones throughout their
menstrual cycles affect their behaviors
as consumers?
And so I look at these biological
underpinnings specifically in the
consumer setting.
So do you think that most behaviors,
most human behaviors are linked back to
genetics more than anything else?
I know you've talked about this.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah.
And it's the nature versus nurture
argument and things like that.
But would you say that's really where
the stuff we're made of?
I mean,
certainly there are biological
imperatives.
That's our part of our shared,
you know,
human nature,
but there's always an interaction
between our genes and our environment
and the.
I always love to use a cake metaphor,
so if you take the ingredients in a
cake,
the,
the baking soda and the flour,
the sugar,
the eggs,
they're each separate ingredients.
Then you put them altogether,
you make a cake.
If I were to tell you now point to the
exit point of the sugar,
you wouldn't be able to.
It's an inextricable mix and so much of
who we are as an inextricable.
It makes of our nature and nurture.
The problem with most social scientists
has been over the past hundred years is
that they have doggedly refuse to accept
that biology matters and so their
position has always been,
yeah,
yeah.
Evolutionary theory is relevant to
explain the behavior of the dog and the
mosquito and the zebra,
but don't use their.
Apply it to human behavior.
We transcend our biology.
What makes us human is that we are
cultural animals and that's silly.
Well,
I mean if you were just to look at
people being gay,
would that be an argument against that
as well?
Right,
because when they buy that logic,
they would say you could override it or
something like that.
That's right.
Exactly.
Of course,
that's one example,
but there's a Zillion,
right?
I mean,
I mean it,
it.
It behooves one to understand how
serious academics could genuinely
believe that biology doesn't carry much
importance when it comes to
understanding human affairs,
but it really originally started from a
very good place.
A lot of miscreants use evolutionary
theory for nefarious goals.
Right?
Hitler misused that.
A eugenesis misused as a social class
elitists in Britain and said,
hey,
the upper classes are better than the
lower classes.
Who cares if the little classes dot,
hey,
that's the Darwinian of course had
nothing to do with Darwinian theory,
but because of all these cretins misuse,
evolutionary theory,
social sciences said,
okay,
well let's create a new understanding of
human nature where biology is no longer
relevant and hopefully there won't be
these types of abuses,
but that's silly.
I mean,
you have to route your science and logic
and reason.
Yeah,
so my whole a direct message at the top
of the show is talking about academia
and sort of the ideas that are,
that are working in colleges and mostly
that are not working and the free speech
problems we're having,
which were hugely here in America,
but I know it's happening in Canada too,
and it's happening all across Europe
right now.
Um,
and you're,
you're right in the thick of that
because you are outspoken.
That's what,
why we connected in the first place.
I saw this guy on twitter and I was
like,
wow,
this guy gets it and he's not afraid to
say it.
So,
um,
what,
what do you think the general atmosphere
or,
or talk about for your experience,
what's the general?
So you might have seen it.
I recently delivered a lecture on
political correctness and the thought
police and I gave many of these
examples,
which if,
if they weren't true,
you would think it's straight out of the
onion.
I mean,
it's really just an impossible to
imagine that the fulcrum has,
has swung so much towards lunacy.
Uh,
I think we have to fight it.
I mean,
the reality is that most academics,
uh,
I hate to keep repeating this point,
but are afraid of their shadows.
They're careerists,
uh,
to the extent that the general
environment is,
you have to coddle the,
the students.
You have to infantilize them.
Don't you dare say something that might
offend them,
then they perpetuate the problem.
But if enough people stand up
courageously and say,
look,
this is not right.
As my five.
I've had this discussion recently here
with some college students,
uh,
and I,
I explained to them that it's not to
your benefit,
uh,
to have professors be terrified to speak
to you.
There's a,
there's a great article that I can't
remember the name of the professor who
wrote it,
basically said,
uh,
my students terrify me.
That's not a good thing.
I mean,
if you're a student,
you don't want to hear that right?
You want professors will challenge you.
Who,
who gets you to move from your
positions.
If we are afraid to utter a one syllable
that might somehow,
uh,
necessitate you going into a safe space,
it shatters the possibility for
dialogue.
Yeah.
So when you say that to students,
I'm going to guess that on an individual
level,
if you're sitting across from them,
they probably do get that they probably
don't understand it,
but that when you get them in a group
and the group think star,
that that's where it becomes dangerous.
So mom,
so how do you combat that patiently by
demonstrating through evidence that this
is ultimately suboptimal and it will
only hurt your growth?
Right?
I mean,
people learn by engaging the diversity
of ideas.
I mean,
that's what learning is about.
And so,
and I explained to them that I'm very
open to somebody coming to see me and
saying,
look,
I've experienced this in this trauma and
therefore I need this particular,
uh,
you know,
acquiescence and fine.
I mean,
I'm an,
I'm an empathetic person.
I'll take that into account.
But to have,
for example,
a trigger warning that is sufficiently
vague that it covers every possible
thing that might trigger somebody.
That's not a good idea.
Right,
so let's dig into the trigger warning
thing a little bit.
So there there would be trigger
warnings.
For example,
if you were teaching a course and you
were going to discuss rape,
they would a certain amount of people
that that like these ideas would want
you to issue a trigger warning so that
in case someone that was in the class
had been raped or their mother had been
raped or their sister had been raped or
whatever it is,
they would,
they would receive notice before
discussing it.
I know that doesn't sound terrible in
and of itself,
but it's,
it's the pervasiveness of it,
right?
It's the way that it then sort of
shelters you from really dealing with as
well.
And the reality is that it's not
restricted to a few examples such as
rate becomes everything.
It's everything.
As a matter of fact,
I,
I took,
I took it upon me to actually generates
a list of topics that have been
suggested as possible.
Topics that would be worthy of a trigger
warning.
And actually I covered that in my,
in my lecture,
and basically those topics that I
generated would pretty much cover
anything that anybody could ever talk
about soccer.
That'd be then,
I mean,
yeah,
I don't know how it could be,
but yeah.
And yet here we are,
we're,
where do you think this started?
Because that's the part that I find
really interesting and I did discuss it
a little bit with Tarek.
Um,
where did this idea that you have to be
protected come from and how did it
proliferate so quickly?
Well,
I think it comes from different sources,
but political correctness is really the,
the,
the impetus of all of these subsequent
movements,
right?
The idea that there are certain things
that you should not say.
And then we take this idea and then we
say,
well,
there are certain things that you
shouldn't say it because it makes people
feel uncomfortable or it hurts them or
triggers a past trauma.
And so it becomes the way that I've
described that there's a,
and it's a speculum hypothesis right
now,
but it's certainly worth testing is a
phenomenon known as Munchhausen's
syndrome.
Uh,
which basically says,
uh,
a woman,
typically it's a woman who suffered from
this disorder,
uh,
we'll try to feign an illness to 10
garner sympathy.
Then there's Bush Munchausen Syndrome by
proxy where you harm your child or your
pet or your elderly parents to try to
then garner sympathy.
But I think this type of crying for safe
space is sort of this growth tests,
collective Munchhausen Syndrome,
right?
Where people get attention by constantly
screaming victim hood.
And so it becomes a very alluring way to
navigate through the world.
I always get attention by saying that
I'm offended,
I'm hurt.
I'm,
well,
I escaped execution.
I could still watch a military movie I
want from now on,
whenever I walk around in any city,
you shut down all movie theaters,
that's military because I was going to
be executed in Lebanon to do it.
God,
I mean,
it's really nuts when you,
when you,
especially when you lay out like a great
metaphor like that.
It's like this is because we could all
do this and that's why every,
what do they call it?
You know,
it's just like the afflicted Olympics or
the oppression and the oppression
Olympics.
It's like,
it will never stop.
Yeah.
And I see this now as,
as a disease that's running rampant and
that's why I talk about it so much.
I can't imagine that this will continue
as I already see a lot of academics
write to me privately,
uh,
saying to me they don't yet have the
courage to come on board publicly,
but they say,
you know,
thank you for speaking out.
Thank you for being a voice of reason.
This has empowered me to try to be a bit
more open.
And I think all it takes is for a
flicker to start.
And then eventually I think the tide
will shift back.
I think.
Yeah.
Well that's nice to hear that they're
privately do that.
But do you get pushback from professors
that think a gads pushing this too much?
I don't get it to my face because I'm,
I'm,
I'm a formidable guy to go against other
ones.
You better come with all your guns if
you're going to do this stuff with me.
Yeah.
So usually it doesn't happen directly,
but I will hear from,
from sources that such and such person
is upset that I'm taking these
positions.
So I know that there are groups that are
upset with me,
but they don't necessarily come to my
face and say.
Right.
So this is a great argument for tenure,
right?
I mean if you have tenure rights.
Oh yeah.
Since 1990 $9.
Ninety nine.
So when you got tenure,
did that change at that moment?
Did they,
what did they do?
The hand your paper.
How does it work?
They,
they,
you kneel down and.
Well,
it's actually a committee.
It goes through several layers.
And then finally use,
receive a letter saying that you've been
granted tenure.
Yeah.
Uh,
the process of applying for it as you
basically give your whole dose here to
demonstrate that you're worthy of that
honor.
W,
what are the protections you actually
get for tenure?
I mean,
they just can't fire you just like that,
but there must be some Grazia.
What if they run out of money?
If the university closes?
Only if your department would have to be
closed for financial reasons,
then that would be ground for them
closing the department.
The fact that you a tenured wouldn't
protect you,
but the purpose of tenure is really to
make sure that,
let's suppose I'm doing work on
evolutionary psychology and the Dean as
a young Earth creationists who thinks
that evolution is a Zionist hoax.
Yeah,
right.
Well,
he or she can't come to me and say,
Hey,
you better stop this evolution stuff
because it offends me and it makes our
university look bad and I'll fire you.
Right?
So tenure is a means by which you ensure
that a good ideas are able to be pursued
because oftentimes most of the important
ideas or dangerous ideas,
they're ideas that go against the
orthodoxy.
They're ideas that are considered
critical at the time.
Right?
Think of Galileo,
think of socrates,
right?
And so the,
the idea oftentimes and in political
discourse,
politicians will say,
oh,
we've got to get rid of tenure because
all these facts,
professors sit around doing nothing.
Yeah,
that's,
that's basically them saying that
they're idiots because it's admitting
they're not doing their job.
Tenure is there to make sure that you
could pinch pursued dangerous ideas.
Now regarding my specific context,
even when I didn't have tenure,
I was outspoken.
Maybe not necessarily about trigger
warnings because there wasn't.
Right?
But in other words,
I never modulator that my behavior maybe
to a fault.
Maybe I'm not enough of a careerist I
just,
I don't care.
Uh,
the,
the pursuit of truth for me is greater
than any careerist considerations.
Yeah.
Well,
I love that and I know that to be true
from you and that's why your channel has
been picking up steam and while you're
talking to so many great people,
and I think part of it really is because
of exactly what you wrote about in this
book,
that you're approaching the political
topics that we're talking about and the
religious topics from a scientific
place.
I sense that that really is the bedrock
of what you do as a scientist.
That's what you're trying to quantify
and qualify all of this stuff.
Exactly.
And I saw your interview with Bill
Warner,
who is also a scientist and a,
an uh,
you know,
he studied all of the religions,
right?
He said he studied with Moms,
he studied the Qur'an and he studied
with rabbis and Jerusalem,
the Old Testament,
all that.
And,
and I thought he said something very
similar that as he's looking at these
things as a scientist,
not as a sociologist.
Exactly.
And do you think that's really the
healthiest way to listen?
And actually that's one of the reasons
why.
I mean,
of course I receive negative comments
from people and hate mail and so on.
But given the types of positions I take,
they're actually quite,
quite few of them precisely because I
approach it in the manner that I do.
Right.
So whenever I take a position,
I make sure that it is documented as it
would be if I were submitting a paper to
a scientific journal.
Right.
So my,
my evidentiary threshold is set so high
that it becomes difficult to break it
down and therefore people can accuse me
of hate speech and this and that because
everything is backed up.
And the case of Bill Warner,
for the viewers who may not know this,
he basically applied the tools of
content analysis to then quantify the
amount of hate that is found in
different different religious texts so
we don't have to have a vacuous
discussion about whether Islam is
peaceful or not,
whether the Old Testament is peaceful or
not.
I can actually use the tools of science
in this case called a content analysis
to quantify how much hate there is in
this book.
And,
and that becomes unassailable well.
So with the assailable part b though,
that what's in the book is only only
matters depending on the amount of
people that act on it.
Right?
So that's not,
that's not unassailable in its in its
scientific method,
but that's what the real issue is,
right?
The real issue is not what's in all
these books as much as how many people
are acting on it.
But that sounded almost Reza Aslan,
which to me didn't get me out of that
because residence I fully.
I mean,
look,
we know these books are all nuts,
right?
Because they're all filled by,
written by men thousands of years ago,
but it's not really what's in them as
much as how people act on them.
So,
so Reza Aslan basically used the,
uh,
the worst thing anyone's ever said to
me,
my,
my deep apologies.
Reza Aslan basically use the,
a BS argument from postmodernism to say,
you put your meaning exactly.
So you know,
who are we to judge whether kill,
kill,
kill means that kill,
kill could mean a stroke with kindness
and correct.
Right?
No,
it doesn't.
Okay.
Yeah.
A language has accepted beaning and no
amount of postmodern gymnastics is going
to alter that.
Right?
So I guess what I think what I was
saying is that if you looked at the
three books,
and I think by most accounts that the
old testament's probably the most
violent of them,
but no one would really acting on the
violence of that.
So that doesn't discount that it says
some horrible stuff,
but if nobody's acting on it then it's
sort of irrelevant.
So I hope,
I hope that's not how postmodern,
because I know,
I know that exact quote from him and it
sounds like pure,
so we could get into the theological
discussion.
I mean,
one of the,
for example,
if in the Old Testament says killed the
alumni alumna kites a while they don't
exist anymore.
So even if I was desperate to act on
that,
Edx I wouldn't be able to.
On the other hand,
if a,
another religious book has a,
the following tenant killed the
nonbelievers wherever you find them.
That is actionable today.
Uh,
so,
so no,
the argument that.
Well,
it depends who acts on it.
That's not true.
There's very plus we don't have many
people today that act on Deuteronomy.
Well that,
that was my point,
that it depends on who's acting on it,
but that doesn't change the specifics.
Exactly.
That are,
that are in the tech.
Fair enough.
Do you find that as an academic and as a
social scientist and all that,
that it's exhausting talking about
religion because you don't believe in it
so that,
you know what I mean?
Like you're trying to add something
rational.
This is what I feel.
I'm constantly trying to rationalize
things that cannot be rationalized
anymore.
It actually also in your discussion with
Bill Warner,
he said one of the interesting things
about the current is you can almost
rationalize anything because you can say
something's really great.
Yeah.
So can you explain to a little bit?
So the idea is so people don't know
that,
uh,
the Koran has what's called abrogated
versus so,
uh,
God might have decided through the
revelations to say,
uh,
there's no compulsion in religion.
And then later God is allowed to change
his mind and say,
killed,
you know,
don't be so tolerant.
Right?
Right.
Well,
how could it be that a and not a can
coexist?
Well,
through dual logic that can be allowed
in the way you do that as through
abrogation,
which basically means that when you have
two techs that contradict one another,
the later texts texts supersedes the
previous one.
So when people typically quote the
gentle passages from the Koran,
that's the Meccan period,
those passages have actually been
abrogated.
They've been made null and void.
So now in some cases,
the people who who,
who quote those passages know this and
they are actually being duplicitous and
other cases they're unaware of this
aggregation mechanism.
All right,
so let's just talk about Reza for a
minute since you brought him up.
And he and he,
because he's become such a player in
this space and CNNS even giving him a
show all about belief,
which sounds just horrific.
Um,
when he plays those games,
you know,
right.
You know that he knows this,
he knows about what you just described
and yet he's doing this.
So what do we do with these players?
You know,
what do we do with?
It's a great question because I don't
know.
What has endgame is.
I mean,
as it is,
it that he's engaging in self deception
as we know humans are very adept at
doing.
There's actually some very interesting
evolutionary arguments for why people
engage in self deception.
You want me to take off?
Let's go there.
Okay.
So,
so the argument for the evolution of
self deception is that when you and I
are chatting a,
we're engaging,
if you like an Imac,
a valiant battle,
I'd like to get you to do what I want,
but I don't want you to know that I'm
doing this right.
So when I'm lying to you,
they are typically markers and made that
you're trying to pick up to see if I'm
being duplicitous or not.
The way that I shut off those markers as
by first convincing myself that I'm not
lying.
In other words,
by engaging in self deception,
I shut off the mechanisms that you might
otherwise read in me that I'm lying.
Interesting.
So,
but is that a fully conscious decision
on the part of the person that's doing
it as an evolutionary mechanism that's
been built into us now?
So,
uh,
you know,
signed on Seinfeld,
there's a classic episode where George
Costanza says to Jerry,
I might get the quote wrong.
Remember Jerry,
it's not alive if you believe it.
Yeah.
Uh,
actually talked about this in one of my
earlier books.
Uh,
well that's,
that's the idea.
So,
so I don't know,
in [inaudible] case whether he truly
believes the,
the just the endless tsunami of nonsense
that he produces or whether it's just a
duplicitous attempt.
He,
you know,
this is the way by which I've become
very famous.
This is the way by which I get a lot of
attention because I'm sort of the Brown
guy from Iran who could appear moderate
and so on,
and I'm going to stick to that niche
because it's got me a lot of fame.
So I can't tell which of these two
possibilities he's under.
You know,
it's so interesting because when I hear
you say that,
it clearly comes from a place where
you're trying to give him the benefit of
the doubt,
right?
You just went out of your way to not say
this guy is a duplicitous liar or
whatever.
And you know,
Sam Harris says how intentions matter.
Right?
And you're trying to say,
well maybe his intentions are good.
So that would be a reason to fiddle with
some of this stuff.
I sent that all the people that,
that we argue with all the time,
they would not give us any of those
passes and that to me shows you where
this battle really is happening right
there.
There's,
there's kind of a,
an immediate reflex to label anybody
who's in our space,
you know,
a Nazi and Hitler and Himmler,
right?
That's right.
Yeah,
I agree.
Uh,
I mean I've been fortunate.
Again,
knock on wood,
I haven't had too much of this stuff.
Maybe because I am quite measured in how
I speak and maybe because I come from
that background,
it gives me a layer of protection which
maybe Sam can't have.
I'm not exactly sure,
but I've been fortunate in that sense.
Right.
So to what my question that started this
whole thing,
using scientific method to discuss
texts,
not this text.
What religious texts that aren't
necessarily based in rationality or in
secular values,
do you find it exhausting?
I mean,
having,
right?
Like are,
do you find yourself spending a lot of
time deciphering things that we
shouldn't be worried about anymore?
We don't worry about what scientists
thought 3000 years ago.
So why are we worried about what
religious people thought?
$3,000.
It's extraordinary,
right?
Because if,
if you take a belief that someone holds
and you don't cloak it under the robe of
religion,
then this would be tantamount to the guy
being schizophrenia and let's commit
them to a mental hospital.
Right?
But we can give a good example of that
because I think that's a really great
point.
Uh,
okay.
So,
uh,
this profit has gone on a winged horse
somewhere.
Yeah.
If I say that,
hey,
you know,
I believe that,
uh,
Dave Ruben,
yesterday,
I saw him on a winged horse going to
happen,
then we're good mushrooms.
Then I would call a,
my clinical psychologists or
psychiatrists,
friends and say,
hey,
let's try to commit Dave Rubin to a
psychiatric hospital.
On the other hand,
if I say the exact same thing,
but it is cloaked under a religious
narrative,
don't you dare criticize that narrative,
right?
So the exact same statement is either a
form of lunacy or perfectly acceptable
religion depending on whether it is
protected by religion.
And that's grotesque,
right?
I mean,
why is your belief in whatever narrative
you choose to believe somehow sacrosanct
and I can't touch it.
Yeah,
so when it comes to religion and
obviously we've spent a lot of time
talking about this and I've had mostly
people that are anti religion,
but just last week I had an ultra
orthodox,
ultra Orthodox,
but Orthodox Jew,
Ben,
she mentioned thought made some pretty
cogent arguments separating religion
from politics even though I didn't agree
with him on a lot of it,
but I thought he did an interesting,
you know,
he wasn't trying to govern.
I sense from a place of religion,
which I could at least respect that,
but what do you make of the general
feeling that,
you know,
you watch the superbowl in the second
last superbowl and they thank God these
are people who spend their entire lives
training to become machines of
athleticism and the team that lost also
but also pray to the same guy,
but somehow God really was for the
cardinals.
So he hates the trailblazers.
I'm mixing sports.
You make sport that I really got it.
I really do not support support of that,
but I'm,
I'm,
I'm trying to think of A.
Yeah,
so,
but,
but to me that what that shows is not a
belief in God per se,
as much as it shows almost a
narcissistic disorder,
the Lord of the universe.
And I mean if only people would have a
sense of the vastness of the universe,
uniquely cares about a point guard who's
about to make a three point closing shot
and if he makes it.
Oh Lord Jesus.
Thank you Jesus.
Really be invested in your,
uh,
career stats.
Yeah.
And by the way,
we can also take examples.
It would be like,
you know,
if you jerked off or something and then
felt guilty after because God was
watching you.
It's like he's watching you do that.
He's watching basketball.
Better things to do.
I mean really if without even more like,
I know there's a certain mocking tone
here,
but without even mocking it,
if you,
if you really believed in this,
wouldn't you believe that God would be
doing something else?
Creating another universe.
You know what I mean?
Really.
Otherwise it seems so silly.
He's quite pedantic,
but I'll give you.
I did A.
Actually,
it's in this book where I,
I,
I played this following a mental game.
Suppose you had a Martian who came to
earth and he's shopping for the one true
religion,
and so he asks a bunch of questions.
Am I allowed to wear leather shoes?
Can I have a tattoo?
Am I allowed to be to have homosexual
relations?
I mean,
you think from the most mundane to the
most a metaphysical questions.
I demonstrated that for every possible
question that you can generate,
I could identify two religions that
prescribe the exact opposite thing to
that same question.
I mean,
if that doesn't serve as a devastating
blow to the whole scam of religion,
nothing was.
Right,
right?
Let's put it another way.
There are 10,000
documented religions in the world.
You,
I bet you 10,000
now here.
What I mean is different than
nominations of Christianity with
countless different religions,
right?
Right.
So there are 10,000
of them.
The only thing that they typically have
in common is that each of them says that
I'm the true religion.
The other 9,999
are false.
Credible.
That sounds a bit fishy to me.
Right.
And also that they are all designed
differently.
I find that when I'm,
when we're debating a lot of this stuff,
um,
you know,
especially with we've gotten almost 40
minutes and haven't said regressive,
so I'm finally going to say the word
progressive and regressive left,
that they always want everything to be
equally as bad except some religions
want people to convert into them.
Some don't,
right?
That would show that,
not that it's necessarily better,
but it would show that certain people
don't want to spread their ideas as much
as other people,
but there is a need on the left to go.
Everything's bad.
And once you do that,
you're actually saying nothing.
Right.
I've actually used that same argument,
but in the end,
under the context of an academic
setting.
So there's,
there's a concept known as a meme.
Are you familiar with that?
Of course.
So this is from Richard Dawkins,
right?
Well,
Richard Dawkins argues that religion is
a Mima plex.
That's a collection of memes and memes
spread very much.
Like how viruses spread or how genes
propagate and populations well,
or or how meme spread on twitter.
Right?
Exactly.
So to go to your point about religions,
some religions that the content of their
memes are inherently infectious.
In other words,
the transmissibility of that religion is
much greater.
So in Judaism,
the fact that you you don't proselytize
is precisely the reason why they are 13,
14,
15 million Jews depending on how you
count,
right?
And the whole entire universe world,
they are $50,
million Jews on the other hand and a
religion where you're allowed to
proselytize and there are other things
that you can do all.
So for example,
it takes very little to get into the
religion.
In Islam,
for example,
right in Judaism,
if you truly wish to convert according
to the strict tenants,
you can't just sort of say one sentence
and we'll welcome to the right of the
Jewish clan,
right?
You actually have to go through a very
costly process.
So there are all sorts of mechanisms
that you could study in the context of,
of a religion that demonstrate why one
spreads and another one doesn't.
Right.
And by the way,
using the example that you just
mentioned,
it's also a lot to get out of Judaism
because they not a Jew anymore,
nobody cares.
But if you were to get out of Islam,
we know this with the PA states all over
the world,
you might get killed on,
but to kill means to correct.
So you're just sounded right.
So,
okay,
we take all of this.
We,
we get it.
You think that this mode of thinking is,
is not great for the world and,
and all of that.
You want to use things from a scientific
place.
So when I had Peter Goes,
you know,
and he wrote a book called a manual for
creating atheists.
Yes.
And I read it and I thought it was
really great book and I've,
I've tried to use some of those,
uh,
practices when I've talked to people
about this stuff and I asked him,
does he think that like what's the
difference?
At the end of the day,
if someone holds some of these beliefs
but isn't doing anything nefarious and
isn't pushing these ideas on anyone,
do you still think it's bad?
And he basically said yes,
because he,
he said,
uh,
I'm not quoting him exactly,
but that you're diluting yourself and
that's not really what the point of
being human is.
What would you say in that case if
someone just picked some beliefs?
It's nominal.
Nobody cares,
you know,
and you're not oppressing someone or
making women dress a certain way.
Right?
So,
I don't know,
it depends if I want to be pragmatic or
a purist,
if I want to be pragmatic,
I say you don't believe whatever you
want as long as you don't impose your
beliefs on third parties that I don't
care.
So that's the pragmatic part.
If I were to be a purist,
right?
Uh,
the pursuit of truth matters than I
would agree then with Peter that to
believe in these types of fairytales is
actually injurious to the human spirit.
Right?
So that in and of itself,
even if it's not propagating violence or
something on someone else,
that it's against the sort of human
nature or something like that.
And if anything,
I mean,
and,
and many atheists have talked about
this,
a,
there is a wonder that you can access
without needing religion.
What religion does in a sense is it is,
it,
is,
it covers the capacity.
I mean,
I can go and see a beautiful landscape
and be transcendent,
transcendent by the experience without
needing Booga Booga to,
to,
for me to actually experience that.
Right?
So it actually cheapens life to always
have to contextualize it within the
context of a big data in the sky.
That's interesting.
I think I've told this story on the show
once before,
but I want ate pot brownies and I was
going to see air force one with friends
and it was sold out.
So we moved,
we went and saw contact.
Did you see contact?
This is what the costs are.
And it was written.
It was Carl Sagan is only fiction book.
Uh,
and um,
I didn't know what the movie was at all.
I had no idea what we were walking into.
I don't know if you remember,
but the opening scene was this
incredible panorama of the universe.
And I ate these pop around,
he's,
I was basically like tripping out of my
mind and the whole movie just blew my
mind apart.
I was like,
this is amazing.
I ended up reading a whole bunch of
Charles Dickens books and all that and
it sort of led me to a lot of the things
that I think now,
but the movie ends,
she has this sort of a,
not that satisfying experience because
she can't prove that what happened to
her actually happened and the movie ends
with her just looking out on a sunset.
And that's exactly what you're saying,
that there are ways to,
I suppose,
feel connected and feel a part of this
thing that don't necessarily standing up
and sitting a lot at a.
actually that was one of the starting
points that got me away from religion.
We were sitting at a synagogue,
a again Avraham in Beirut.
Okay.
Uh,
and I asked my father,
you know,
I'm confused.
When do we stand up when we sit down?
And he's like,
you don't shut up.
Just the fact that he said that really
upsets me because already as I don't
remember how old I was,
maybe five,
six,
seven,
uh,
that left a hole in me.
Well,
what'd you mean?
Why am I standing up and sitting down?
They give me an explanation.
So the fact that there was sort of this,
this dogmatism a is probably the
starting point of what led me astray
from religion,
but to come back to atheism,
I've written an article in psychology
today blog where I talked about carpet
den,
right?
Seizing the day.
And that atheism is really consistent
with that ethos,
right of living in the moment,
right?
There are no do overs,
there is no eternal life.
It's now is the relationship that I
formed.
Now it's the,
it's the knowledge that I helped spread.
Now it's the goodness that I can impart
to the world.
And so that actually makes it a much
more a wonderful experience to realize
that you have a very short,
limited time.
Now,
of course it's very scary,
right?
I mean,
you and I want this party to go on
forever and that's why I think actually
that religion will never a sister exist.
We'll never eradicate it because we will
never resolve the problem of our
existential angst.
Right?
So when you say the word eradicate
there,
I know that the,
the,
the progressives who have launched this
huge assault on new atheist,
they sort of came up with this term new
atheist and I guess originally it had to
do with a hitchins and Sam and Daniel
Dennett I think,
and who is the fourth?
I think there was a fourth in there,
Sam Harris,
Richard Dawkins talking,
sorry,
but the idea that these people,
these new atheists,
they're not just atheist to believe
whatever the hell they want to believe.
They want to destroy religion and I
think they spread this meme as a way of
silencing people who would critique
that.
That to me is all they've done here
because I have now I know many,
many atheists.
I know no atheist that is trying to use
violence or intimidation in any way to
stop anyone from believing anything.
Sure.
They may critique you,
they may ridicule you,
should they be quiet,
but why should they be quiet now?
Shove your religion.
I mean,
all day long.
I should,
I should be quiet.
And my non belief why,
I mean,
I'm not suggesting that you should ever
be and polite.
I mean you can be nice and you can be
polite about it,
but I have to be quiet.
I was quiet when I was living as a Jew
in Lebanon.
I didn't want to be quiet anymore.
So that's.
So,
that's really interesting.
So that the,
all it is,
when they say new atheist,
all they mean really is an atheist who
speaking up.
And that's what,
that's what they hate more than any of
you seen some of my,
a satirical traits of our new atheism.
I'm sure I've said,
uh,
I,
I used to weigh 200 pounds,
then I put on 10 pounds.
I'm now a new atheist.
I used to have this skin tone.
Then I went on vacation.
I became the new atheists is a term
that's complete nonsense.
Yeah.
Um,
alright.
So we're going to do a little more of
the,
uh,
the regressive stuff when we sit down
with Lalo and a little bit,
but I'm just curious for you personally
as you've been part of this discussion.
And again,
we just sat down for the first time in
August,
so we only met about eight months ago.
I probably only knew of you on twitter
for maybe three,
four months before that.
As you've become part of this.
I'm curious how much of it,
how much of it consumes you actually
like that?
Because I know how personal this is to
me.
I know that I have trouble shutting it
off sometimes at night and I don't mean
just my phone,
I mean just the thought process and
feeling that,
that there is something big going on
here that were part of a.
How big does it feel to you?
It's a very big.
And often,
I mean I would say that the last six
months I've spent maybe 50 percent of my
time working on these types of issues as
opposed to say Mike sort of classic
scientific career.
Precisely because I,
if you like,
I defined my role more broadly than just
as somebody who's a professor,
right?
I mean,
I can engage the public in the battle of
ideas and,
and frankly I'm quite disappointed in
many of my colleagues who don't think
that way,
right?
I mean,
nobody is contesting the fact that it's
really important to do your great basic
science.
I mean,
that's what you are,
you're a professor,
you're a scientist,
but if you've got the capacity to
reason,
then it is,
it is important for you to also
participate in battles of ideas that are
outside your very limited,
uh,
lab studies.
Right?
And so in that sense,
I actually have been quite consumed by
some of the issues you're saying now
where I sometimes regrets my
participation is when I don't know when
to stop aging some ass who's constantly
hounding me.
Now in many cases I'm able to disengage,
but in a few times they kind of,
they trigger you in some way and then
you engage this person and you realize
you just wasted an hour and a half
speaking to somebody who was in his
underwear and his mom's basement.
Okay.
Yeah.
All right,
well I'm going to dive more into that
with you and allow a little bit.
Um,
all right,
so look,
we could talk forever and this is my
second interview in a row where I
haven't even picked up my,
my notes once.
Um,
but because I started by talking about
college and that's what you just brought
this to you.
Um,
what,
what's the hope Gimme Gimme the point
for some of this turning now I guess we
can talk about this stuff and we see it
that there is this now movement growing
of people that aren't afraid of speaking
and all that stuff.
How do you as a professor,
a fuel that you can win this and did you
feel it right?
It's,
it's precisely and empowering every
single individual to engage the debate.
Right?
I receive endless private messages from
people whom I've never met them.
I'll never see again.
So you don't just because I watch how
you behave and how much you've got to
lose professionally and if not also
personally,
I mean in terms of threats and so on.
Uh,
this has gotten me the courage to speak
out against some of my regressive
friends on facebook and I just spent
three hours taken on these guys and I
wouldn't have done it had I not seen
your courage.
So basically all you're trying to do is
to empower people to feel as though they
can make a difference.
And by having enough of that,
because think about it,
the regressive left is quite,
uh,
an invested in this fight and all you
need to do is stand up and offer a
counterpoint and get enough people to do
it.
Truth is on our side,
we will win.
Yeah.
So that's what enrages them more than
anything else to wrap this up.
That's what enrages them,
is that they've been sort of unchecked
example all the time.
Right?
Like,
because they were.
Because the right in a lot of respects
has gone off the deep end so that there
was no rational argument to be had.
Now here come us and it's like,
oh,
we're going to have some rational
arguments,
but they have been doing the whole cries
of racism,
not a monopoly.
Yeah.
And there's a new company that's
offering another product.
They're not happy.
Yeah.
What we're going to beat and with better
ideas.
What do you say?
We will.
Let's do it.
Alright.
Well it was a pleasure talking to you of
course.
And for more of guides that you can
follow them on twitter at Dad's.
That uh,
his youtube channel is in the
description below and there's something
big coming.
We were going to be working together
pretty soon.
We're going to discuss that with Lalo.
Thanks for watching.
And we'll do it again next week.